la commission européenne autorise la
france à convertir un prêt de 3
milliards d'euros en fonds propres
paris peut également monter au capital
en injectant jusqu'à un milliard d'euros
une recapitalisation d'air france à
hauteur d'un peu moins de 30 % faisant
de l'état
le premier actionnaire de la compagnie
aérienne selon bruno le maire le
ministre français de l'économie
bruxelles a donc approuvé le projet
d'état français mais a aussi imposé ses
conditions
en contrepartie air france devra céder
18 créneaux de vol à d'autres compagnies
aériennes d'orly ce qui représente
environ 4% de ses créneaux sur cet
aéroport parisien
la montée au capital c'est quelque chose
d'indispensable
on ne pouvait pas continuer sur cette
trajectoire là ça va dans le sens de ce
qu'on demandait ce n'est pas de l'argent
injecté ce sont des prêts le scandale
c'est d'avoir cédé face à la commission
céder des créneaux c'est mettre en
difficulté l'entreprise même si c'est
moins que les 24 créneau prévu
initialement
l'aéroport d'orly est un petit aéroport
ce n'est pas à munich ou francfort
qu'est ce qu'on va faire des salariés
qui travaillaient sur l'activité qu'on
va céder 8500 emplois doivent être
supprimés d'ici 2022 au sein d'air
france et de sa filiale régionale
hop un plan de transformation de la
compagnie aérienne pour surmonter selon
la direction la crise économique et
l'effondrement du trafic passager lié à
la pandémie de coronavirus au delà d'air
france c'est tout le groupe air france
klm qui est à la peine l'entreprise
franco néerlandaise prévoit une perte
d'exploitation d'un milliard trois cents
millions d'euros au premier trimestre
2011 21
le groupe qui a déjà été très fortement
touchées l'an dernier par la crise du
coc vie 19
air france klm a perdu 7 milliards
d'euros en 2020 et vu son chiffre
d'affaires s'effondrer de 59% par
rapport à 2019
une déroute à l'image de l'ensemble du
secteur aérien mondial